how are you both doing good area to an
excellent I want to start pissing
congrats on the movie Thank You salt
last night I laughed a ton which is yeah
so I have to imagine this had to have
been a fun shoot or am I completely
wrong no it was really fun I mean I
think Betty and I had totally different
experiences but yes yeah I mean I really
worked I I do think I work two days on
the movie and it was mostly by myself so
when I watched the movie I was like wow
crazy time together but it was also fun
the scenes I did but it looks way more
entertaining yeah I was gonna say when
you got the role did you know that
because a lot of your scenes are on the
phone yeah and I'm like I'm thinking to
myself you know you signed up you're
gonna be with all these people but not
really I mean I I did make sure with the
director I was like it's not just on the
phone to like we're gonna do camera
setups in her room right like it's not
just gonna be me like in the corner of
it it was like no no we're gonna film
you talking on the phone as well cuz you
never know yeah true this is the
buddy-cop genre is an evergreen genre
that's gone on for so long do you have
any favorites in this genre or um I
always liked a lethal weapon yeah I
enjoy a lethal weapon yeah yeah and I
just worked again with this director
Michael doubts on another buddy cop
movie with Ed Helms that Oh fun is the
one that comes to mind now it's gonna be
great no no completely I actually want
to talk to Michael about that
specifically um but I actually want to
talk about working with Michael because
it's hard to toe the line between like
successfully showing cool action
set-pieces as well as humor it's like a
skill set that you really have to have
so talked a little bit about
collaborating with Michael and what he
brought to the table and maybe what
impressed you um he was really really
open to collaboration he was really open
to hear our ideas and very open to
improv which is always so fun for
especially like comedians to do you know
it's definitely something I enjoy doing
I tell myself it's my strengths and I
and I like doing it a lot and I think it
just makes it feel more real
especially if you're with another actor
who is good at it also and like feels
comfortable with you like a lot of my
stuff with Kumail or Dave was like that
and it was really fun yeah yeah it can
it's a little scary when the environment
on set is very anti improv and very wood
you know there's one right answer to
something and it does I think it's
reflected in my work when I feel like oh
I guess there's one way to do this I I
do I come across less like it's really
happening and Mike Dow is being so open
to improv I think it shows in the movie
that it seems like it's all really
happening and the stakes are sometimes
wildly unrealistic yeah completely
I got a few fun questions for you let's
see if you think they're fun what TV
show would you love to guest star on
that's a good one
oh man big little eyes first movie or TV
show crush ooh
Jane's older brother and Daria even
though he's a cartoon whoa yes what's
his name I don't remember any more times
like that
really yes I'm him or Montel eclectic
taste was nurturing I enjoyed it
what kind of different as it could
possibly okay this isn't just because
you're wearing that shirt but Ray Liotta
in Goodfellas life but when I was little
like that's not it's disturbing for me
to have that crush yeah what's actually
might be disturbing is how many animated
characters people have told me when I've
asked this question like Jane's older
brother or Daria oh well that's why
don't you watch a lot when you're a kid
you watch cartoons I see Jay I know I
think you're right it's it's a
one-syllable thing what TV show have you
watched all the way through more than
once hmm I don't know that I've done
that really no because I feel like
that's a waste of time because it's peek
TV man there's so much TV out there I
can't argue with uh you know what uh
Game of Thrones
uh here's why because I convinced
someone to watch it recently who had
never seen it before the last season so
I watched all of the seasons with them
what about hopefully forgot everything
that her for the last season came out so
I did do that with that one most of the
episodes every watch with them sure I
guess friends and Seinfeld is my team
because there are like Sex in the City
yeah okay um what movie have you watched
the most ooh that's a good question
West Side Story oh wow suprisingly in
time I've watched a clueless a lot yet
Eternal Sunshine a lot and Moulin Rouge
yeah by the way there's nothing wrong
with that all right so good nothing and
then Blue Crush that oh yeah big movie
in my life donor highschool days we
would just like throw on the Blue Crush
do the time though over 40 times I was
gonna say Dazed and Confused from it ah
yes also dancing can you uh can you
watch yourself on screen or do you
become super hyper critical no I think
it's important to watch yourself at
least for me on screen it's like it's
like if you're an athlete and you watch
your game and you go what did I do wrong
or did I today it helps you build your
craft when you're aware of what you look
like when you're trying to do something
and you're like did I succeed at that or
did I not I think it's important to be
aware of yourself I've a slate between
being too neurotic and not caring yeah
like ten years ago when I first started
acting I was like would just spiral
about it and now I'm a little more tired
and less I don't have less critical of
yourself yeah that's good um what was
the last thing you were really obsessed
with whether it be a movie a book a game
a fleabag I need to say I need to just
sit down and watch it you should it's
only six episodes in two seasons okay
I've heard this from so many have you
not seen it I haven't the second season
is somehow better in the first which was
amazing wow that's so good and the
second season is the last it's finished
so they're only doing two yeah it's
British TV men they know they know yeah
uh killing Eve
oh yeah say yeah everyone another one on
my list oh what's the secret to having a
great relationship with your
cinematographer oh saying thank you
present for the light yeah yeah thank
you for the light
yeah when they do that nice light on you
you're like thank you so much you're
thinking about my face
yeah I'm not Greek yeah should say thank
you for the light more I have to ask an
individual question I am a big fan of
glow
I know season three is coming yeah what
can you tease people about it I know
that it's mostly in Vegas yes it's it's
all in Vegas and it's about us doing the
show within the show kind of the
floorshow version of our crazy wrestling
show and you know things continue to get
weirder and the stakes get higher and so
do the cuts on the body suits Oh
question also um I loved into the
spider-verse
you got to voice yes and in that what
what did that mean to you because the
movie is phenomenal yes it's such an
amazing movie um I mean I I really had a
great time working with those guys and
even though it was a small part I was so
happy to be in that movie it's also like
completely revolutionary if this like
you know black Latino kid is spider-man
it's awesome it's so awesome and I'm it
was a thrill to be a part of it